SURGICAL MASKS, WANTING TO
PROVIDE 1,000 MASKS TO ANYONE
WHO NEEDS THEM.
JON: THANK YOU, ALICIA.
>>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS HE IS
CONSIDERING PUTTING SOME PARTS
OF THE HARDEST-HIT STATES UNDER
A 14-DAY QUARANTINE, AMID FEARS
THAT NEW CORONAVIRUS HOT SPOTS
ARE EMERGING.
THIS ALL COMES AS THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION IS UNDER THE
MICROSCOPE FOR NOT ACTING FASTER
WHEN THE FIRST CASES WERE
REPORTED IN CHINA.
DR. DAN FIELD IS CHIEF MEDICAL
OFFICER AT MD STAFFERS.
HE JOINS US NOW.
WAS THERE A LAG, DO YOU THINK,
IN REPORTING THESE -- THE
SERIOUSNESS OF THIS VIRUS
OUTBREAK WHEN IT ORIGINATED IN
CHINA, DR. FIELD?
>> I THINK THERE WAS A
SITUATION.
IT IS HARD TO KNOW WHO WAS
RESPONSIBLE WHEN THE FIRST
REPORTS WERE COMING OUT.
THERE WAS MISINFORMATION.
I DON’T KNOW THAT IT WAS
WILLFUL.
I DON’T KNOW WHEN THEY WILL KNOW
THAT.
I’M KIND OF FOCUSED ON MOVING
FORWARD AND NOT LOOKING BACK AT
THAT PART OF IT.
JON: RIGHT.
SO LET’S LOOK FORWARD OR LET’S
LOOK AT WHERE WE ARE NOW.
I MEAN, IN THE NEW YORK CITY
AREA, THE STREETS ARE EMPTY.
TIMES SQUARE, WHEN I CAME ACROSS
IT TODAY WAS DESSERTED.
PEOPLE ARE TAKING SERIOUSLY THE
ORDER TO STAY HOME AND STAY OUT
OF CROWDS.
WILL THAT BE ENOUGH TO BE
EFFECTIVE?
>> WELL, IT’S VERY IMPORTANT
BASELINE I THINK THAT WE HAVE A
WHOLE NEW SET OF BEHAVIORS THAT
WE REALLY NEED TO ADOPT, AND AS
OUR SOCIETY ADAPTS TO THE
CURRENT SITUATION, WE MAY BE
SENDING SOME PEOPLE OUT TO WORK
WHO WORK IN SOLITARY
PROFESSIONS, LIKE GARDENERS AND
TRUCK DRIVERS, AND THE REST OF
US WILL HAVE TO REMAIN IN HOMES
OR MORE SECLUDED SITUATIONS, IN
ORDER TO KEEP THE CURVE FLATTER
THAN IT IS RIGHT NOW.
JON: DO YOU SEE ANY BRIGHT SPOTS
ON THE HORIZON?
IS THERE ANY GOOD NEWS COMING
OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC, IN YOUR
VIEW?
>> WELL, I DO SEE GOOD NEWS.
I THINK THAT AMERICANS HAVE
REALLY RISEN TO THE CHALLENGE.
I HAVEN’T HEARD A LOT OF
GRUMBLING.
I KNOW THAT MY COLLEAGUES IN
THEIR HOSPITALS HAVE KIND OF
TAKEN A BATTEN DOWN THE HATCHES,
LET’S CLEAR THE DECKS FOR ACTION
ATTITUDE.
SO HERE IN THE SACRAMENTO AREA,
THERE HASN’T BEEN -- THERE HAS
BEEN AN UP TICK IN THE NUMBER OF
CASES, BUT IT HASN’T REACHED THE
LEVEL THAT WE’RE SEEING IN LOS
ANGELES, LOUISIANA, NEW ORLEANS
OF COURSE, NEW YORK.
MY COMPANY, FOR INSTANCE, IS
DOING ITS BEST TO MATCH DOCTORS
WHO HAVE SOME EXCESS CAPACITY
WITH PLACES HOSPITALS AND
CLINICS THAT NEED THEIR HELP,
PARTICULARLY IN TELEMEDICINE,
WE’RE GETTING A FLOOD OF CALLS.
WE’RE WORKING 24/7 TO TRY TO
MATCH THOSE DOCTORS WITH THOSE
NECESSARY SLOTS.
JON: THE DOOMSDAY PREDICTIONS
THAT, YOU KNOW, EVERYBODY WAS
HEARING WHEN THIS CRISIS REALLY
FIRST STARTED BUILDING IN THIS
COUNTRY, DO WE KNOW YET WHETHER
THOSE ARE ACCURATE?
>> WE DON’T KNOW RIGHT NOW.
WE’RE STILL A WEEK OR TWO AWAY
FROM GETTING THE FEEL.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE CURVE OF THE
INFECTION RATE, WE’RE STILL ON
AN EXPONENTIAL RISE, AND WE’RE
GROWING FASTER THAN ANYWHERE
ELSE IN THE WORLD,
UNFORTUNATELY.
OUR DAILY CASE LOAD IS REACHING
UP AS HIGH AS -- [INAUDIBLE].
JUST TWO DAYS AGO, IT WAS LESS
THAN HALF THAT AT 8,000.
WE’RE IN A DANGEROUS TERRITORY,
BUT I THINK THERE’S REASON TO BE
OPTIMISTIC THAT MANY PARTS OF
OUR COUNTRY HAVE HEARD THE
MESSAGE AND ARE PRACTICING
SOCIAL DISTANCING.
WE OF COURSE IN OUR BUSINESS ARE
SENDING ANYBODY WHO DOESN’T NEED
TO BE IN THE OFFICE HOME, AND
WE’RE SPREADING OUT THE
WORKFORCE TO MINIMIZE THE RISK
OF INFECTION.
EVERYBODY’S BEING MORE CAREFUL
ABOUT SNEEZING, COUGHING.
I THINK THAT WE COULD WEAR MASKS
TO PREVENT THE TRANSMISSION.
REMEMBER, HERE’S THE TRUTH, THAT
FOR EVERY PERSON WHO HAS TESTED
POSITIVE, THERE ARE AT LEAST
EIGHT TO TEN ASYMPTOMATIC
PEOPLE, PEOPLE WHO DON’T EVEN
KNOW THEY HAVE IT WALKING AROUND
WITH THE INFECTION.
SO MAYBE MORE MASKS WEARING WHEN
WE HAVE THE MASKS AVAILABLE WILL
BE HELPFUL.
BUT THERE IS REASON TO BE
OPTIMISTIC THAT WE’RE NOT --
WE’RE NOT GOING TO SEE OUR
COUNTRY CRUSHED BY THIS.
JON: BUT IT IS ALSO TRUE THAT
YOU DON’T WANT, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE
WHO HAPPEN TO HAVE ACCESS TO
M-95 MASKS, YOU DON’T WANT THEM
WALKING TO THE GROCERY STORE
USING THAT MASK.
THOSE SHOULD BE RESERVED FOR
MEDICAL PERSONNEL IN HOSPITALS;
RIGHT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
RIGHT NOW, THEY DO NEED TO BE
RESERVED THERE, BUT WHEN WE MOVE
FROM A POSITION OF SCARCITY TO
ONE OF SURPLUS, WHICH WE
PROBABLY WILL IN THE NEXT
SEVERAL DAYS OR WEEKS, THEN WE
MIGHT SEE EVERYBODY SPREADING
THE MASKS AROUND TO FURTHER
REDUCE TRANSMISSION, AND SINCE
YOU MENTIONED KIND OF HIT UPON
HOARDING.
I REALLY WANT TO SPEAK OUT
AGAINST HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE
HOARDING THAT I DON’T KNOW THAT
THAT’S AN ISSUE ELSEWHERE.
I KNOW THAT NONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES ARE HOARDING THIS
MEDICINE.
I PERSONALLY AM NOT, AND I THINK
IT WOULD BE TERRIBLE.
I ALSO DON’T THINK THERE’S ANY
STRONG EVIDENCE THAT IT IS DOING
THE JOB THAT WE’RE HOPING IN
ELIMINATING THIS VIRUS.